wow that's a loud ass car
oh it gets that this neighborhood is a
real challenge this neighborhood is
scary
yeah at night it really is
it's a whole other neighborhood at night
all right christy christie uh where'd
you grow up where you from originally
um from salt lake city utah does that
mean you're mormon
i am not lds but i grew up around a lot
of mormons
but not your family no my dad's side yes
they tried to convert me to mormonism
when i was about nine and i just didn't
do it there was just something
in me that just said not to do it so i
didn't i think you're the third or
fourth
woman who's done sex work who's come
from that
community it's interesting yeah i know a
lot of girls in utah that do sex work
a lot is that right is is there
you you know i think the majority of the
pop the world thinks that utah is very
conservative and straight and no one
does anything
like that yeah there's a lot there it's
just kept
like more quiet i guess
no secrets yeah there's guys out there
that actually pay like twice as much
money
for some of the same services that like
in la and vegas like
girls are doing things for like maybe
150 on the streets
out there you could get like five to a
thousand oh wow
yeah i know some of the pimps will take
their girls to salt lake city probably
i've heard of that i've heard that yeah
i've i've heard that as well
so how'd you grow up you had you had mom
and dad um i grew up my mom was a
single mother my dad
was kind of one of those hippie he
he was like one of those hippie
deadheads and he was just really into
heroin
and mushrooms and drugs and he um
didn't really give a [ __ ] that i was
around and uh
i grew up with just my mom and she kind
of was a serial dater she's on her fifth
marriage right now
and my dad's been in and out of my life
but the last time i talked to him which
was
uh when covid happened he told me he saw
my only fans and he said
that i was a [ __ ] and that he hopes i
die from the coronavirus
so i blocked his phone number
how would you describe your childhood
with your mom
it was pretty traumatic it was it was
not fun
i couldn't wait to move out of her house
for what reasons may i ask um
there was a lot of there was a lot of
abuse she married a guy
who was in the military he took us to
italy and virginia
and he was just very abusive to me and
my mom i would have to listen to them
fight and him hitting her all the time
and i was only nine i remember one time
they were fighting at kitchen dinner and
he chased her up the stairs
and i was listening to them fight above
me and um
and he hit her really hard and she fell
on the floor and actually thought she
was dead
and i was like nine and then like an
hour later he came downstairs
and he was like okay we need to go to
the hospital you need to stay here and i
was like i'm not staying here i'm going
with my mom
and i watched my mom lie in the hospital
and say that something else happened but
he really
put her there and so it was scary when
we were living in italy
um they made me go to school and no one
there spoke english i
there was one teacher that spoke english
and it was a sub
and they made me sit in class like all
day long
as an english-speaking child nine years
old and they all spoke
um italian and so i mean i picked some
of it up and learned some of it
eventually but it was just like we were
all the way out in this other country
with him and he was beating the [ __ ] out
of us
and um and it was just really scary i
felt like
like really stuck there as a child like
it was scary
so so you left home without your parents
care at what age
right when i turned 18 i met my son's
dad
and we moved in together like right away
i kind of couldn't wait to get
away and we were together for about a
year
and then we had a baby and i had my son
who's 14
now you raised your son
i raised my son until he was 11.
and then when he turned 11 um that's
when i decided to move out of utah
and move to las vegas and try to get
start my life in a little bit better
he likes utah so just let him stay there
have drugs been a part of your life um
often on yes
right now i'm staying clean but i've
done
meth for a while um when i was 16
i got into meth in utah
um you know like back in the 90s it was
technically considered like the meth
capital of the world
for a while and um
i did that and then i actually got into
cocaine um
in my 20s when i was work doing a lot of
sex work
and i was like drinking and coking out
with everyone
and i mean it was fun and it was really
easy to you know like
talk to people and be that happy like
person that's just having a good time
but really it was destroying me you know
on other levels
and so i took a break from it but then
when i moved to vegas this last time
i quit doing sex work but and i started
working for a famous street artist and i
started working at a record store
but at a tattoo shop but all my bosses
did cocaine
and they were giving it to me so i was
not doing sex work but then i was doing
cocaine again
but i started getting really thin and
sick
and so for the last about six months now
i just i won't do it anymore
i'm trying to gain weight and i've been
eating a lot better and i've been trying
to exercise i bought a bike recently
and i bike a lot and i just don't want
to
i want to like love myself better
so sex work for you started when
i was about 23 and i started doing those
uh seeking arrangement sites
i just got divorced from my husband and
i had debt
and i'd never had debt before and um
a friend of mine was a dancer and she
was like you should go on
this sugar daddy site and i didn't
really know like exactly what it was
like kinda you know
but i didn't know how dark it really was
you know what i mean
so i went on and i found a guy
and he took advantage of me really bad
um and you know what's weird is that he
still contacts me to this day through
social media apps and i don't like to
talk to him
and he watches me everywhere i think
so you've branched out from that you you
got into what other kind of
sex work i started doing um sensual
massage
after that because i don't like having
sex for money
it disgusts me a little bit so um i
started doing sensual massage
because then i don't really have to have
sex you know
so um i started doing that and i did
that for seven years
consistently
how was that i mean your experience
doing that was
that that was okay for you um
at first it scared me
um i had an ex-boyfriend that
introduced me to it and told me you know
why don't you go do this and i really
know what it was
but i had a feeling that you know and i
was like okay if i go in there and they
want me to get into a bikini then i know
exactly what this kind of place is
and um right when i got there that's
exactly what happened
was they were like okay we're going to
have all of you guys get in a bikini and
we're going to show you how to do
basically new so it's like
using your body to do the massage and uh
so they taught us that and
the money was good but it was super
sketch and weird in there every day
um it was sad the things that were
really going on in there now that i
think about it
but i was in my early 20s it's been
about almost close to 10 years since
that happened
um but it was it was weird but i just
kept going because like every week
you know you started getting regulars
and they always like the new girl so the
new girl always makes a lot of money
that's why these pimps take girls to the
cities all the time
because they're the new girls so that is
always
a boost for someone who's trying to do
that that type of job is if you're new
guys always want to see you because they
get tired of the same girl
around and um but
i just consistently kept making more and
more money like every month every week
so i just kept going back and doing it
got i started getting out of debt and i
started being able to live in like a
nicer place
and buy things i could never afford
before so
um yeah i just kept going back and then
it started getting
huge i started getting a mass
amount of guys
um and i had guys to do
everything for me i had guys to take me
on trips i had guys to take me to dinner
i had guys to be intimate with i had
guys to treat like [ __ ] i had
whatever i needed whatever i wanted it
was really crazy
for a while and the money solves all
your debt problems
it did i and i made um roughly around 90
000
a year for a couple of years and i saved
some of that money and then that's when
i decided to go to school
because i knew eventually i had been it
was going seven years into it
and i remember i was i was in this
beautiful condo that i had
and i was taking a shower one day
and uh i remember i was really unhappy
and alone and i just but i had
everything
i had you know this nice apartment this
really nice car
and i had like a closet full of louis
vuitton but i was in my shower cry
and i was like okay this is time
to shift it's time to shift
so i had some money that i had saved and
i was like what do i want to do with it
okay i'll go to school
got to get a career i want to continue
being successful person and making money
but i don't want to just sell my body
for i don't i didn't want to be like the
40 year old
stripper in the club i just didn't
and so i saved some money and i decided
to use it and go to paul mitchell
to do hair oh good for you and makeup
that's great yeah that's what got you
out of the
doing the massage work um no um
i kept doing massage work while i was in
school
to help pay the bills because i was
going to school full-time so obviously i
wasn't making any money i was just
spending
on school and
because not all of it was paid for some
of it was financed
and um so i continued to do massage work
on the side and then i got i graduated
and i got my cosmetology license
and then after that i um
kept doing massage to actually fund my
booth rent
for my hair station and then not long
after that i
ended up getting busted by vice doing
massage doing a massage oh you got
arrested
i didn't get arrested um
i didn't get arrested they let me
go
they let me go um how did that happen
i i was doing a massage on the sky
and he started asking me weird questions
and i knew right away that it was
the cops so i started asking questions
and then
they knocked on my door and i looked out
the door and there was like
nine cops outside of my apartment door
and they just
rushed in and i had like just lingerie
on in it and i was freaked out and i ran
into my bedroom and they were screaming
at me and they were like don't
close the door don't get dressed so
i was just like [ __ ] like i [ __ ] up
and all i could think about was my son
and just like
i just felt like i [ __ ] everything up
at that moment i was just like
okay it's all coming crashing down right
now
and um the cop
sent all the other police out of the
room and he sat down with me and he said
you know we can make this all go away
for you
you know if you want to do um some some
things with us
and help us we can make this all go away
for you and
i tried to help these cops kind of work
with some stuff that they were doing
but nothing really came of it and they
actually got frustrated with me because
they thought they were going to nab a
whole bunch of other people
through me but i was working
independently and i didn't have anything
they were like
you know someone making you do this like
and i just told them no
like i just do this by myself and they
were trying to get all these other
people's names and information to try to
see if maybe like they could do another
big bust but
i truly 100 worked for myself didn't
have any information i didn't like
working for other people i didn't want a
pimp the girls were crazy
and jealous anyways so i stayed away
from them and um i couldn't help them
so eventually he just let me go into
and he told me that my case was just
going to be dismissed
and um i asked him if i could move to
vegas and get out of salt lake city and
he and he said yes and we put that in
writing
and um and they just let me go back to
vegas
so you got away i did i left
and i haven't done um any massage or sex
work since that day
except for except for only fans so now
you're
[Laughter]
no you're a cam model i am which is
which is the new
way for girls digital digital
sex tell me how how that's different
than
the one-on-one escorting or massage
thing
there's just no physical contact it's
all over the phone
technology marches on it changes
everything doesn't it yeah
is it easier better it's a lot easier
less uh less unpleasant i guess yeah and
i
i
you know because i didn't like having
people come to my house i don't know how
girls are always so comfortable with
having an in-call at their house
i hated it i hated it yeah that's gotta
be a weird feeling to have these
i mean i would do rooms sometimes too
but
sometimes you will do it at your house
because you don't want to get a room or
something
if you have a place those girls will do
it at home
and it just started making me feel
really uncomfortable so only fence is
nice because nobody knows where i live
nobody knows where i sleep i don't have
to touch anyone
nobody touches me so
i like that and
you just use your phone and you shoot
and that's that yeah i mean i
sometimes will use my webcam i also have
a camera too like a nikon
and i have a leica and um
yeah i do a lot of self-shooting um if i
i do i know a ton of photographers
because i've been a model for like 20
years but
so i know a lot of photographers and a
lot of them are usually down to shoot
some stuff
and i'll i have a little process i'll
always do like a couple of uh
social media safe stuff and then i'll do
the
the paid that's how i kind of
bait people in like if you want to see
more you can see the full video here
and with your roughly decade of of doing
all this
these are different variations of sex
work what's your take on it
i honestly wish that i would have never
did any of it
um but it's a fun lifestyle
um depending on what you do with it you
know
i think some girls get in a really hard
like place and
some some are forced some get into drugs
but there's some girls i've seen that
are so successful
you know i know very successful women so
i don't know what my take is on it it's
i'm i'm very
like on the fence i'm so back and forth
about it
it seems like there's a price to be paid
for everything we do true there is a
price for everything and i think for
everybody
you know i also still look at some girls
that you know they're like oh i have six
kids but i would never escort
well okay so you're just giving it away
for free
i hate to kind of sound like one of
those girls but i mean
why give it away for free
i can totally understand giving away for
free if you're with like a certain
person you just love them
fine perfect but if you're just going to
randomly hook up with people
i don't know
yeah the decisions we make in life are
very very interesting aren't they
yeah some people some people like to be
loose and
you know some people are more hustlers
i'm i'm a hustler
so
and what's your does your family know or
anything like that they do
they do my son doesn't really know your
dad knows but
dad knows dad doesn't like it
right is there are there emotions that
come from doing it
yeah yeah yeah especially when i was
more physical
the physical ones like massage and
escorting i used to get really depressed
like shame or something like that yeah
and i would sometimes just get grossed
out with my body when i was
showering after clients and stuff it's a
weird feeling um
it didn't make me feel very good
sometimes it made me feel really
powerful but most of the time it didn't
make me feel very good and yeah i mean
there was there was definitely some
depression
i think the drug use along with it also
is like a huge form of the
depression too because i think that just
like what you're trying to do with the
drugs is numb out the fact that you
probably don't feel good about what
you're doing
you know so it's just a domino effect
downward spiral but
um i don't know i mean there's so many
people that
it it's all in just what you do with it
and how you and how you
how you do it i guess yeah i mean there
are some
women that i think maybe they're built
for it but
i don't know i don't know i just i have
a hard time
buying 100 percent that that they're
cool with it and it's all good and
they're happy all the time no truth they
claim to be
i truly don't believe that they are
i even i even know male porn stars and
even then
i can see
that they probably regret
a choice or two you know
i can even see it in in some of the male
talent
it seems to me that we're all meant to
love ourselves that's the biggest
challenge
we all have and it becomes very very
difficult to do that when you're
selling your ass yeah if you i don't i
don't think that i think it's hard to
love yourself and also it's hard to feel
that grounding
um it's hard to love yourself if you're
if you're walking a straight line
yep then when you start doing sex work
then it becomes
well i believe highly in like the
spiritual realm
um so i don't know if you've ever heard
of like there's that term of like
however many people you sleep with when
you sleep with someone else you're
sleeping with like all of their like
spiritual realms of the people that
they've slept with
and i believe that so i believe if you
have sex with someone
especially like without a condom
you're going to take on a lot of
negative
energies from people that they've been
with
and it'll go into you yeah
in a spiritual aspect um
so i'm weird about sex i actually
haven't had sex in two years
is that right yeah i mean aside from
with myself
yeah i haven't had sex since july of
2019.
is that cleansing for you in some way
um my last relationship my ex-boyfriend
was
sexually assaulting me and it took me
almost two years to get over it oh yeah
yeah
that's a good reason yeah i met him when
i when i moved to las vegas in 2018
and he just totally [ __ ] me up
he [ __ ] me up really bad he would make
me take down all my modeling pictures
off of instagram
and on tags from other photographers as
well
just the bourdoir ones because he was
like i don't want anyone to see my
girlfriend like that
and i was doing it and it's like i would
have been a model for 15 years
professionally and um and i was like
yeah i love you all do you know that's
why if it makes you uncomfortable of
course like i got you
and and um after i did it
i felt like a part of me was missing i
was like hey wait that's not right
if it's part of my past okay you don't
want to do it anymore fine
but it's my past you can't just erase it
it's who i am it's what has brought me
to
you today you know what i mean so
um yeah but he was sexually abusing me
um
and i don't know if i'm
fully like okay from it but i mean it's
been two years
yeah but i just um i've really haven't
been able to open myself up sexually to
anybody that's
for a long time it might be good to take
a break and just ease back into it
yeah when it feels right so
having done all the sex work over the
years what what have you learned about
men
and their behavior
all right so men all think the same
kind pretty much they have the the same
thought processes
they have their own little routines in
their head
i know guys don't like rainy days that's
that's a really good day
to get a client on a rainy day on a
rainy day
a rainy cloudy cold day guys want to be
in bed
interesting um
guys are pretty easy to figure out um
males are my favorite
i love i love men so it hasn't jaded me
i don't hate men
um i hate people for the things that
they do
um but i think men are just kind of
funny i think they're easy
to figure out and um
yeah what kind of what kind of strange
behaviors have you seen though
all these girls that have done this kind
of work have these
stories that just make you roll your
eyes at men
so i had this sugar daddy once that
we would get a hotel in salt lake all
the time really nice on the monaco
we'd have dinner and then we'd go to the
room and fool around
and this one time he had me get on all
fours
in front of the mirror because the
mirror kind of went down to the floor
and he had me get on all fours and he
was having sex for me from behind and
was making me make out with myself
on the mirror and that was really
strange
i also had another guy once in park city
get a hotel room with me and he had this
briefcase within the silver briefcase
and i was like oh
man what is in here and he had all kinds
of weird stuff and i actually made him
get into a bathtub
and shave his uh genitals and then i and
then i made him sit in the bathtub while
the water drained out
and clean it up after and he had this
fake dildo that actually squirted out
like liquid
like like it would become or whatever
but and um
he was like tell me to teach him how to
give him [ __ ] and stuff with that
so they're strange sometimes
i also had kind of still having other
clients
um that i do dominatrix for
and um the other day he had a
chastity belt on that has a key and i
hid the key in all my clothes
and i said okay you gotta go find the
key and i was like whipping him
you're not finding it fast enough
so that are interesting yeah there's all
kinds um and they all want something
different
it's not usually the same they all have
a different scenario
idea so you're
so are you content to stay here doing
what you're doing or do
do you think there's other avenues for
you down the road i would love to not do
only fans
oh you want to get out completely yeah
from sex work yeah
good for you i've been trying for about
three years now
and it's hard for all the reasons that
we just talked about probably
yeah like i started working at a
dispensary this year and that's nice
i do production in the back so i just um
package things all day
i don't have to deal with any clients i
don't have to deal with people i don't
want to uh
handle any money um i listen to music
whatever kind of music i want all day
and i just handle marijuana and
packaging and um that's been nice
i go home and i smile and i'm like ah
you know it feels good
this is what it should feel like what
would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
compassion
compassion
there's a lot of people that don't have
it i have no time for those types of
people
but if you just have compassion it just
lives with you
you know and um
very healing yeah
when you give it to others yeah
all right christy thank you so much for
sharing your story thanks i wish you the
best of luck with your new direction
thank you thank you very much
you